wordle was the kind of thing that when i
found out as people were talking about
it i decided i'm going to not know what
this is for as long as possible so i
still don't know what it is i don't know
what wordle is i don't know i've never
heard you i knew that
what is it it's like uh
scramble
scramble he's naming it it's all menu
items with him he's like oh it's like
moods over my hammy scrabble you mean
it's it's you put you make words out of
some [ __ ] it's one of the new ones
it feels like some chin replacements
ramble i played with it one time i did
scrabble with my sister's ex-husband one
time and he was the
this is like my half-sister's ex-husband
and he was the uh
he with his words were like wood acts
like two words hyphenated it's crazy
like it was just the worst you call him
out or was you
i was like oh that's good i let people
do it yeah
i let people do it nick i feel like your
your grandma plays [ __ ] wordle is the
older person's game no it's kind of like
i'm sure they're old word games like it
but it's online they do one word a day
and you have to guess it and if you
guess a five letter word it tells you
what letters you have right and you get
six tries have you ever seen the show
lingo with chuck wolvery no absolutely
not that's a big game show not work out
i heard about it uh you know you look
like that you look like a big game shirt
yeah yeah oh yeah definitely midwestern
you grow up you watch the game shows
that's why it's very important
no whammies
yeah i know that one no emmy's only
zombies
dude you know the hardest [ __ ] show
is the taxi one what's the taxi one
right now benjamin button no benjamin on
with uh
cash cab oh tough man when they get past
like two thousand dollars jesus but a
lot of people nobody faked that and
they'd be like they got a girl would get
in the cabin like hey you know i'm going
to try to [ __ ] you you know jesus christ
it's like this is cash cash yeah yeah
yeah there's no lights that's bang bust
yeah there's also no handles on the door
that's true they get in it's like
all right what have we got you guys want
to play weirdo what do we do i'll do it
right now five letter word
smash snatch catch catch all right
what'd you say smash let's go with catch
uh okay good catch catch
we got it we won so h is in the right
spot and there is a t in it but not
there
oh wow hat uh
oh no i don't hatch okay
what about touch no because the c
oh okay interesting work
part of the reason it took off is
because they only do one a day what
about broth
why do they only do one a day
just
just to keep people on the hook
so so does that mean there's a oh it's
in the wrong place yeah what about month
smash would work maybe
bam what get the [ __ ] out of here dude
that mtv degree paid off doug that's
sure so that's it that's not what we're
doing about this time baby
theo was pretty good at it i was pretty
good right he was pretty [ __ ] good at
cats bro i didn't know you could read
like catching the broth in the morning
i didn't know you could even read that
was impressive man i want to go on his
phone and see if he's plays word what an
idea he
dude unreal bro but yeah some guy made
it for his girlfriend because she liked
word games and then it got acquired for
like 10 million dollars by new york
times that's it
wow mm-hmm it's a world famous game only
10 mil well now it might be famous
let's go
brought it full circle and put on the
whole team legendary trio
what you mean you know it's the king and
the sting and the wing
[Music]